- Nigger, you know you could
have been with this bitch
all day. He was going
all motherfucking day.
You missing cell and all that.
You feel me?
Cause you want to be a dummy,
because you want to follow some pussy.
You feel me?
And I can't follow no nigger.
Because the nigger can't do me nothing.
All he can fucking make
me do is bust some nut.
And a bitch don't even
do that half of the time.
You feel me?
Please let me know when you're ready.
- [Mark] All right. Destiny.
Destiny, where'd you grow
up? Where are you from?
- Okay. I'm from Las Vegas, Nevada.
And I was from Las Vegas,
Nevada, that's where I was born.
And unfortunately I moved to LA like,
well I didn't move out here,
basically I'm just out here like
on my own being, you feel me?
I'm not here because
I want to be out here.
You feel me?
Like, yes, I did lie to you, I'm not 18.
I'm 17, you know, like.
And yes, I did have a
rough childhood like 15,
when I was 15, I lost my mom.
In two May, 2nd, 2017 I
have lost my mom because...
- [Mark] How did your mom die?
- She had stage four colon cancer,
she had blood clots in her lungs.
Like, I don't know, like when I was 13,
when I was like 12 like turning 13,
I had got turned onto the
game, I was a prostitute.
And it was just like ever since
then, like I was in Oakland,
I'd even been to Oakland, San
Diego, motherfucking like,
I'd have been everywhere
in Oakland, like Richmond
like San Francisco, got to be everywhere,
he took me everywhere in the bay.
He took in out in the
vineyard and Cordon Blades.
Like, it's nothing, you know?
But
I feel like
I should have did something
different, you know?
- [Mark] Already?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Did you realize that at 17.
- No.
Wait, let me tell you something
because when it was like,
when I was like 13, 14,
like it was fun. You feel me?
Like, like, woo. It was super fun.
You don't even know like,
but I wanted to know
why I was attracted that
type of stuff, you know.
I wanted to know why
niggers that got big chains
and gold rings like, and swag
like was always attracting me.
You feel me?
Not attracted to me, attracting me.
You know what I mean?
I ain't gonna lie to you.
Like, like,
drugs, make people do anything, you know.
Personal pull up, like the bitches that'd
be on Agatha and whoring
their stuff like that.
Suck dick, fuck for $20, like $20.
Like that why I'd be
looking like $20, like.
Come on now sis, you got to figure
something like this, gotta
make some more money.
You feel me?
I mean $40, $50 on me, at least it's like,
it's better. You feel me.
Then what the fuck, they, you feel me?
Then you, then you get a high with them
and listen to me, when they pull up,
y'all getting, y'all
going to buy some crack.
That he spent $40 on some
crack and give you 20.
Come on now.
On me like say that, like give
me the whole 60, you know?
But they don't think like that
because they're doing it for the heart
or chasing their heart, you know?
Like I'm gonna chase my dream.
You feel me?
And I'm gonna change my future.
And it's just like, if
I feel like a situation
or if I feel like a nigger,
is going to bring me down
or like get to me, like inside,
where it's going to scar my life.
I'm going to get on. You know what I mean?
Like I'm not going to sit
around and just, no, you know.
Because I know what type of female I am.
You know?
I'm not nobody's bitch.
I'm not nobody hoe, I'm
not nobody, none of that.
You feel me?
I'm somebody clinging,
if I can't be there,
like what is it I'm here for?
You feel me, like,
oh no, it was just like, oh no.
People are, like I swear to God, like
did my ex, like he like, he like
he always used to like
force me to hit the poopy
and slam crystal.
I don't want that shit.
You feel me?
Like, and you know, he'll kill,
I swear to God on my life,
he'll get mad if I don't want to fuck.
You feel me? Like bitch, I'm on my period,
I don't want to fuck you.
You feel me?
I don't want to suck no dick.
We do that shit every
day, like four times.
Like I'm cool. You know what I mean?
Like, like, that ain't what I want.
You feel me?
But he just like, like,
like, I don't know.
Like he like, like I don't fucking get it.
You feel me?
It's just like, he used to
beat me up and forced me.
Like, you feel me?
Like, and that's not cool.
You know what I mean?
Because just how you not giving a fuck,
I couldn't give fuck and just, Oh,
call the police and put you in jail.
You feel me?
Cause you not knowing what type
of female you dealing with,
You know?
But I'm not like that,
because a nigger could get
life out here playing with me.
You feel me?
Because I'm, you feel me?
I'm only 17 and yes I
can call, yeah I won't,
I won't call the police.
But yes, I can call the police,
but this nigger's trying to force me to,
you feel me, have sex with
him, whoop whoopie whoop.
You know what I mean?
Like, and it was just like then, like then
what's going to happen?
You know?
But then nobody thinks like that.
You know what I mean?
They just felt, because
they knew each other for,
Oh this long and this
long, like, like it's okay.
You know. Like,
like it's not, you know, like
it's not.
I swear to God
niggers they turn gay
out here off of drugs.
Like some of the finest niggers
too, like, boy, are you gay?
Like, Oh, no that's crazy.
You feel me?
I swear to God.
You'll see mother, like
it's just crazy. You know?
Like it's just like unreal, you know?
It's so unreal.
- [Mark] Do you ever think, I mean,
did you ever have a goals
of doing anything other than
what you're doing for a living?
- I mean, yeah, don't get me messed up.
On my birthday, when I
turned 18, I'm like, I'm like
I ain't gonna lie to you.
I'm about to, I'm about to
start like stripping, you know?
And then I think that's
something that I want to do.
Like I want to be a stripper.
- [Mark] Did you ever want to be a nurse,
or a teacher, or a doctor?
- Or a lawyer.
And I'm not going to lie to you.
I wanted to be the type
of lawyer that just,
that saves the guilty people, you know?
Because everybody's not
guilty, you know what I mean?
Like there's a reason
why I killed that nigger.
You feel me?
There's a reason why he raped that bitch.
You know what I mean?
There's a reason why something,
you know what I mean?
Like there's a reason
why, you know what I mean?
- [Mark] What is it about
stripping that appeals to you?
- I just like, me I don't
know, like, I don't know, like
(laughing)
I don't know. I don't know.
I just like to have fun, you know.
And I think that would be fun.
Like I know it's a lot
of stuff that I could do,
but I think that
like stripping, it would kinda
like, you know, go with me.
Because when I was younger,
I was praise dancer,
like at church. You know,
like I've just been dancing
like a little bit, you
know, when I was younger.
So then, a stripper.
Strip it.
(laughing)
I don't know.
I don't know. Stripping, I don't know.
- [Mark] I guess it beats hooking?
- Huh?
- [Mark] I guess it
beats being a prostitute.
- I mean, yeah, but that,
that's just a higher class
of prostitution, you know.
Like the stage, you know what I mean?
Like how you got like strippers, escorts,
on like on Backpage, and stuff like that.
Like Snapchat, like
that's, that's, you know.
Besides having to just be stumped down
ten times down to the ground, you know.
And just walking the Figueroa and like,
you know Western and shit like that.
That shit get hot.
And it's just like, they
save you from going to jail.
You don't go to jail.
You know what I mean?
- [Mark] It's not illegal.
(laughing)
- So I just thought that's
like smarter, you know?
And I could probably just be
like a bartender sometimes
you know.
But don't get it messed
up, like I have like,
I had a lot of goals,
you know what I mean?
Like it was just like,
like, Oh no, I just find
like this is fun to me.
Like, Oh no.
I feel like kids are supposed
to have fun differently.
But I mean, I don't know, like
I just like, this is really like
I just feel like this is
getting me ready for the
real life when it comes my
way. You know what I mean?
Because I like, I have
not been living like
like to y'all like I,
when I tell y'all my age
I just like, well you are, you're a baby.
Like, do you feel me?
Cause y'all, like my age ain't
nothing compared to y'all
You know?
So it's just like, like, y'all
be like, man, you was a baby.
Like, like you ain't,
you ain't, you feel me?
Like, they be like, you
ain't do nothing I did.
Like, but half the time,
they all know that.
You know what I mean?
Like this, this situation that I'm in
I could be ready anytime for just like,
I'm ready. Like, I mean like
I'm not going to say like,
Oh, I'm ready to die.
But the life that I'm in
and what I'm doing and how I'm doing it,
I mean ain't no telling
what's going to happen.
You know?
I mean, like being out here
tomorrow 'aint promised.
Being out here today.
I mean shit, you, you, you don't even know
if he going to be in jail.
If you don't know if you going
to wake up the next morning.
Cause, cause I mean, come on
like you went a tail, like, you know what?
Like, you know, but like I
know I ain't gonna lie to you.
Like I sometimes I do like,
just be thinking like,
man, like you know, like, you know what,
I don't know like shit.
It's scary out here.
You know? It's scary. You feel me?
And I don't wish this
situation for nobody.
You know? But this is just temporary.
You feel me?
I don't wanna like,
I don't never like let
nothing get to me. You know?
I'm always, I don't let nothing get to me.
I'm always going... you
want me to close the door.
- [Mark] It's all right.
- All right. So like, I don't like, like
out here, like as you see like
how you have like the mafia
like strunged out, that's
because I think like, yes
they've been out here for a
minute, but that ain't shit.
You know what I mean?
Like you like you too grown
of a cat to be scratching
the ass to buy some drugs.
You know what I mean?
Like, like,
like, let's like,
like this is how I put it,
the people that's out here is the older.
Right?
So, so, so
I don't be trying to
take advantage of them.
Right? But like
sometimes it just be like,
I've got to, you know.
And I just be looking at
situations like, like, like
like you too, like,
like say like you too old
of a dog to be scratched,
like to be like, like to be, like to,
like to be scratched in the
ass, I mean, not even scratched,
like to be bitten in the
ass by a puppy. You feel me?
And he's like, you're too
old to be trying to deal
with a situation or not even a situation,
like not even like, like
you're too old of a person
to still have kid figures, you know?
Like, you know what I mean?
Like to still have a kid,
my mind frame, you know
like people out here they
know like, like, like they
they like, they, they, you
feel me like, this is them.
You know what I mean?
Like people die down here.
Like people like everything,
you know what I mean?
Like today's a funeral going
on, I'm mother fucking serious.
You know?
And it's just like, like,
Oh, I don't get it sometimes.
You know what I mean?
Because it's just like, you
could do anything, you know?
Like your life didn't stop
just because you was in a tent.
You know what I mean?
Like the first day you
got in a tent down here,
no matter what age you was,
you should have done
there something about it.
You feel me?
Like you could have gone back to school.
You like, the ladies out of
here, that's like, you know 20s,
cause what do we do? We
going back to school.
You know what I mean?
Like you could have done
something with yourself,
but no, you let the drugs
take over you, you know?
And like, to be honest, I
don't respect nobody out here.
You know?
Like, like, yes, I like
they call me baby D out here, you know?
Like I'm the baby, you know?
So it's just like, like, like, Oh no,
the Baby's trying to like, like.
You know Baby D off of Friday?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Oh, because that's like a movie.
I'm kind of like, I'm not kinda like her,
but I don't know like, I don't know,
I'm kinda like me, you know?
I'm not downtown just to
be downtown. You know?
I'm only, I'm doing everything
for a fucking reason.
You know?
And it's just like, I've
got goals in life, you know?
And if they don't go high plan,
I mean apologize to me
and my fucking mistakes
that I made as grown up
as a child, you know?
Cause I mean, cause I could
be going to school and be
like, being a nurse or
something, you know.
But I want to rise to academic.
But I'm trying to like give my,
I'm trying to like get
a fake ID, you know?
But like, like, like
that's gonna like pass
like with you guys and stuff.
Because I'm trying to work at the Rio.
That was the only reason
why I came back out
from Vegas though
- [Mark] You want a fake ID so
you can get you can get what?
- So I could like, what?
To go to the strip club?
That's so I can get inside the weed shop,
all that type of stuff.
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
- I want to work. I want
to be a stripper though.
Yeah.
- [Mark] Do you want to be a stripper?
- Yeah.
I feel like everybody else down here
and in my life, even my family
they be trying to like talk down on me.
You know?
Like, Oh yeah, like you only 17.
You supposed to be at home,
going to school, doo doo whoop,
like, bitch, like what you
doing, you was at 17 like,
like would you feel
me, like, I don't know,
you wasn't at school. You feel me?
Because bitch you out
here, you tell me like
you out here for, well I
was at it for 22 years.
Like you feel me?
- [Mark] When did you
drop out of high school?
- Damn, I dropped out?
- [Mark] Oh, you mean, you didn't go?
(laughing)
- I mean, yeah, I went to 11th grade.
I mean I didn't go to 9th or 10th.
I went to 11th though.
And I'm in 12th grade right now.
So basically I mean, I
sure, I dropped out, shit.
Damn, that's fucked up.
- [Mark] Are you still
making money on the street?
Yeah. I ain't going to lie like
but downtown, like they just shut down.
Never catch them downtown there.
Cause they would quote 20, $40.
Like that ain't even me.
- [Mark] Where do you go?
- Like to like Orange
County, Western, Supoveter.
Like it'd be yelling money everywhere.
But I ain't gonna lie to you.
I'm trying to go to Miami though.
Like we're trying to get
some money, money, like
because it's like LA burnt down
kinda like, it's burnt down now.
- [Mark] This neighborhood
is the bottom of the barrel?
Yeah. It's like.
- [Mark] So this is the wrong end for you?
- For me it is. You feel me?
Like I don't stand there and watch.
Like, feel me, like in
the projects and the Pj's
You feel me?
Like, this, this is nothing like,
I'm off in 115th and Willowbrook.
You know what I'm saying?
- [Mark] What's that?
- 115th and Willowbrook.
- [Mark] Yes. I can guess where that's at.
Yeah. But
I was staying over
there, but I don't know.
Like I, I mean,
you know how like, how like
like back when you were
younger, how you had more fun?
Like that's not me, you know?
Like I felt like when I was younger
I had more pain issue like that, you know?
And I would like to run away
from my fucking problems.
You know what I mean?
And just like, I was just
always confused, you know?
Like, because I don't get
why, or I don't know how
or I don't know what for what.
The streets treat me better
than what home treated me,
You know?
But home cared for me and loved
me more than the streets do.
You know?
But, I don't know. You know what I mean?
Like I don't fucking know my nigger like,
when I was a kid, like when I
was, I mean, I still am a kid.
Don't get it fucked up.
But I mean like when I was younger.
But I didn't have, like,
I didn't do nothing.
You feel me?
Like, like, like what is there to do?
I didn't go to prom, I
didn't go to none of that.
Like, you feel me?
Like, I didn't do it.
You know what I mean?
Like, I don't know.
I don't know.
And it just be like
sometimes I just be crying
and shit like that.
Can you feel me? Like
I got the blue bitches.
It would be like I hate
the fact that I got
to the point where all I
could say is, I don't know.
You know?
And I noticed that I said
that a lot, you know?
Like, I don't know.
Like, cause sometimes I really don't, like
cause I know that I fucked
up. Like, you feel me?
I could've, I could've be
doing something better.
You know?
Like
I don't know. I don't know.
And like, I don't, I just
want to know like, why?
That's all I wanna know, like, why?
Like outta all these kids, like why me?
You know, like what did I really do?
Sometimes I feel like it's really like
I was like, I want to feel like,
I want to feel like what it's like,
I don't know what it feels
like to be a kid, you know?
Like I never had fun.
You feel me?
Like
Life is not fair.
Like, like everybody deserves a chance.
Everybody gets a chance.
But it's just like, when I see it
I feel like I didn't, you know?
Cause it's just like damn, I, like.
Okay, me growing up,
having to be called a
bitch all my fucking life.
I don't remember nothing like...
That's really not fair.